a lot of generosity this time of year  for instance community partners and  county commissioner  vice chairman i should say lawrence  weekly teaming up for a day of giving to  help put a thanksgiving meal on the  table for  hundreds of local families they handed  out exactly 300 turkeys  along with boxes of ingredients to make  all those delicious side dishes  a metro sergeant who was helping with  the distribution tells us in a time like  this  everybody needs to pitch in it's really  nice to be there for those in need  it's rewarding we have the opportunity  to do  for people to see us in a different  light versus in  a time of crisis we are able to give  back and help people  when they are struggling especially  during the holiday season  several other community leaders helped  to make today's event possible they  couldn't have done it without anthem  blue cross and blue shield